The John Wick series is a resounding success,
with Keanu Reeves bringing the retired assassin
back for a third feature-length rampage.
There's no better time to break down how the
actor prepares to take on the physically demanding
role.
You might be surprised at just how intensely
he works to become John Wick.
While watching all the insane stunts he pulls
off in the John Wick films, it's important
to keep in mind that Keanu Reeves is in his
50s.
Yet he makes those moves look effortless,
and as often as they can get away with it,
yes, it's really him.
Reeves logged his first screen credit in 1984,
before many of his modern fans were even born.
Since then, the man has given us decades of
badass characters, many of which helped prepare
him for his turn as John Wick.
Understandably, he's starting to slow down
a bit as he gets older, but he still puts
everything he can into his performances.
He mentioned in a profile in Men's Journal,
"I can't do stairs as fast.
But if you say 'action,' I'll go."
"Yeah.
I'm thinking I'm back!"
To prepare for playing John Wick, Reeves goes
through what he describes as a three-month
"John Wick Boot Camp" to help get him ready
to take on the demanding role.
The training regimen focuses on the character's
central concerns: fighting, driving, and guns.
"Lots of guns."
Reeves talked about the routine in an interview
with Page Six, revealing how he sharpens his
shooting skills before the cameras roll.
As he described it,
Reeves said he loves playing and training
for the role, adding that he couldn't wait
to return for a third installment.
Reeves said of Wick as a character,
"You working?"
"...Yeah."
One defining characteristic of the John Wick
films is how effortlessly Keanu Reeves carries
himself around firearms.
He always seems totally in control, utilizing
the smallest amount of energy possible in
order to take out his foes.
There isn't a lot of film trickery involved
in his technique it's mostly just Keanu being
really, really good at handling guns.
In order to prepare for playing an expert
assassin, Reeves works with shooting ace Taran
Butler, a world champion in many shooting
competitions who's served as a consultant
for several different television and film
productions and appeared on competitive shooting
shows like Top Shot and Impossible Shots.
In his John Wick training, Reeves has spent
time with Butler at Taran Tactical Innovations,
a training ground for competitive shooters.
If Chapter 2 is anything to go by, we can
expect the gunplay to get amped up even more
in John Wick 3.
John Wick also possesses some seriously impressive
driving skills, which is something else Keanu
Reeves practices in his preparation for the
role.
Because of the degree of difficulty involved
in some of the set pieces, stunt driver Jeremy
Fry handles the more dangerous tasks, like
pulling off the "flying drift" maneuver in
the second film.
However, a big part of Reeves' "boot camp"
also includes working with stuntmen to improve
his own driving skills for scenes behind the
wheel.
The fancy driving comes pretty naturally to
Reeves, who's a bit of an aficionado in the
realm of luxury vehicles.
He's been known to own a Porsche and several
impressive motorcycles.
In past films, he's sat behind the wheel of
Ferraris, Mustangs, and some impressive muscle
cars of the '60s and '70s.
Reeves' trainers claim that his driving significantly
improved from the first John Wick to the second.
It seems logical that he'd continue driving
circles around everyone in Chapter 3.
One of the biggest problems with many modern
action films lies in the editing of fight
sequences.
Whether it's to hide the fact that the actors
can't really fight or not, many fight scenes
today get edited to the point where it's impossible
to tell what's happening.
But Reeves' impressive martial arts résumé
helps the filmmakers he works with craft much
more impressive fight scenes by allowing them
to use long cuts and show techniques that
other movies can't.
Reeves trained in multiple different disciplines
to perfect the fighting style John Wick uses.
Jiu-jitsu, judo, and practical grappling techniques
are all mixed in with extensive gun practice
to make Wick's abilities look effortless.
The care Reeves takes to get the moves right
helps to save on money, time, and editing
decisions later on.
Director Chad Stahelski, spoke about the production's
approach in the lead-up to Chapter 2, saying,
Keanu Reeves' workout routine for John Wick
serves a dual purpose.
For one, it's tailor-made for Wick's no-nonsense,
explosive fighting style.
His character needs ruthless efficiency, not
bulging muscles, so his workout is grounded
in that philosophy.
On the other hand, Reeves is in his 50s, so
his workout is tailored more to strengthen
his joints and core muscle groups and have
them working in harmony.
Reeves' trainer, Patrick Murphy, has said
that the John Wick workout mostly utilizes
resistance bands in place of free weights,
because they're easier on the joints and help
the body learn more control.
He spoke about the routine with Muscle and
Fitness, saying that the focus was on, quote,
Part of John Wick's massive success is due
to its amazingly choreographed and performed
action sequences.
They often read like dance sequences, and
a big part of that is Reeves' focus on nailing
the moves before the cameras ever roll.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.